tired and hungry
habibusaur and her three young children
are desperate to reach a u.n clinic
at nearly two years old her son hussein
weighs as much
as a newborn once they arrive the u.n
nurse provides them with small sachets
of peanut paste the only meal the family
will have on this day
she says all she wants is to return home
sore fled her village in burkina faso
after it was attacked by armed groups
linked to al-qaeda
and a local affiliate of isil she says
the men were set aside
and shot dead
everything is different now from what it
was in the village
just to have the bare minimum to survive
is very hard
we don't eat enough and we have nothing
to live from
like we used to in the village for soar
and her children
this is now home but these makeshift
camps deep in burkina faso sahel's
region
provide no shelter from hunger the u.n
estimates more than 7 million
people are suffering from acute
malnutrition in the sahel warning
of a looming food crisis with children
most at risk
some of the women here have been
psychologically affected by the violence
and attacks
so how can a woman who is
psychologically affected get her child
out of a cycle of malnutrition
so we have this kind of situation which
is not easy to deal with
the other day i was pulling too much on
this woman and i asked her why she was
always together with her child why why
she said because my father-in-law eats
the child's rations
not enough food too many people hungry
and yet this summer's rainy season
brought the heaviest downpours in years
farmers say the conditions are perfect
for growing crops
and feeding cattle if only they could
reach them
in november burkina faso's president
marc gaboure
won a second mandate with a promise for
a safer future but the fighting with
armed groups
is intensifying and spreading making it
difficult for farmers to return to their
land and caught in the middle
are mothers like habib who can no longer
feed their children nicholas hawk
al jazeera